you know we were all a little surprised
when demi lovato broke things off with
boyfriend and NCIS star Wilmer
Valderrama a few months ago well now she
is opening up about the split and she is
also firing shots at Taylor Swift and
her girl squad
yup Demi's getting in the middle of the
Taylor Katy feud again this time she's
calling out Taylor's friends quote this
will probably get me in trouble but I
don't see anybody in any sort of squad
that has a normal body it's kind of this
false image of what people should look
like Debbie goes on to say I think that
having a song in a video about tearing
Katy Perry down that's not women's
empowerment Debbie gets even more
uncensored in Glamour after battling
bulimia bipolar disorder and drug
addiction the 24 year old revealed her
triggers seen cocaine in movies I've
never watched the wolf of Wall Street I
can
as for her breakup last June with Wilmer
Valderrama the guy who supported her
through addiction and her eating
disorder she says being sick was always
a part of my relationship with him I
always had something wrong with me I
needed to let go of that just beautiful
beautiful right now but it's not all
serious Demi also plays a little
celebrity phone hack game to show off
her fun side my best selfie I guess this
one I'm showing off my new pinkie tattoo
the sexiest photo on my phone I can't
show you that my most used emoji is
probably the cuz I'm a grown-up